le travail reprend dans cette
déchetterie de saint joseph le travail
mais pas la routine pour protéger au
mieux à jean est administré seul un
véhicule à la fois est autorisé à
rentrer sur le site
vous avez quoi
je vais augmenter le sachet en civet 12
à l'école ce matin beaucoup de déchets
verts accumulée pendant le confine c'est
vraiment urgent pour vous cette
réouverture
s'agissant de chez moi donc j'ai
patienté pour s'ouvrir les veines
personnes ont dit c'est des déchets
verts ça ne pollue pas quelque part il
ya la pia pas que la pollution je vais
dire sous le plan de santé et à la
pollution aussi esthétique visuelle dans
chaque déchetterie les à jour ne seront
que deux en même temps pour éviter de
trop se croiser mais aussi parce que
moins de la moitié de l'effectif est
actuellement opérationnel
le port de gants et de masques rassure
ceux qui sont là oui oui oui ça monsieur
qu'au moins c'est que j'arrive à gérer
on a vu ce que ça montre alors repris
vous aviez un petit peu d'anxiété vous
et vos collègues quand même quand même
où il sauve à se voiler la face mais
dans la file d'attenté le public
s'impatiente
les mesures de sécurité imposaient un
rythme qui surprend les habitués ça va
faire une heure que j'attends et quatre
voitures sont passées ça va plus c'est
moi je pense qu'il faut effectivement un
peu de sécurité
à un moment donné tout le monde n'est
pas confiné moi je ne suis pas confiné
donc je ne peux pas dire que j'ai ma
journée pour pouvoir déposer trois ou
quatre ça terme
c'est ce que j'étais en train de dire
c'est vrai je commence à plaindre parce
que je trouve que c'est c'est long je
pense qu'on peut améliorer le dispositif
pourtant tant que l'épidémie sévit rabat
moyen de faire autrement
faute d'effectifs d'abord mais aussi
d'équipements suffisants plus effectifs
sont mobilisés et plus nous avons la
nécessité de fournir des équipements de
protection au l'aller pénurie de masques
se s'impose à nous également
donc nous sommes limités par les stocks
de masques et d'autres projets d'autres
équipements de protection ainsi que du
matériel pour se laver les mains et
c'est en fonction de ces paramètres et
d'autres que nous
que nous évaluons nos capacités à ouvrir
les déchetteries comme tant de choses de
notre quotidien le passage en
déchetterie nous demandera patience
organisation aussi à compter
d'aujourd'hui trois déchetteries sont à
nouveau ouvertes saint-joseph
chateauboeuf et schoelcher et vendredi
prochains sept nouveaux sites viendront
s'y ajouter le morne rouge saint pierre
sainte luce le marin vauquelin françois
et le robert attention ces ouvertures
sont limitées ces sites seront
opérationnels seulement les mardis et
vendredis de 8h à 16h